in my attempt to have a portfolio whose
performance should depend only on my
ability to identify good companies and
to identify bad companies and not be
held sway by whatever the market might
do I have bought a share of Company B
thinking that it's a pretty good company
it'll do better than expected and I have
shorted two shares of company and I've
shorted two of them because it's they're
only at $5 a share and I wanted to short
the same dollar amount so now I want to
think about assuming that I was right
that Company B will do better than
company a relative to each other how my
investment will do if the stock market
moves up or if the stock market moves
down so let's imagine the situation
where the stock market moves up in that
situation you could imagine both of
these stocks will go up so let's create
Company B goes up in percentage terms
more than Company A so let's say that
Company B gets to $15 so it gets to $15
a share so it is up 50% and let's say
that company a only goes up by 20% so it
goes to six dollars a share so company a
only goes up by 20% up 20% so it is now
up to $6 a share so in that situation
what happened I clearly make a lot of
money on Company B on my long position
when the company when the stock market
goes up 10 $10 became $15 so I made I
made $5 there and I clearly lost money
on my short position because I sold it
at 5 and now I'm going to have to buy it
back at 6 if I want to cover my short
position so that 10 so this $10 position
remember if two shares of them are now
worth $12 are now worth $12 two times
six dollars and since this is a short
position I will lose I will lose $2 but
because because the company that I
thought would do better did do better it
went up by more it went up by 50% while
this only went up by 20% I still make
money I still make a $3 profit now let's
think about what happens if the whole
stock market
down and I'm going to assume that I'm a
good I'm good at picking the right
companies so I'm gonna assume that my
thesis holds that B does better relative
to a so let's say in this negative
scenario B goes down by 20% so let's say
B goes down by 20% so down by 20% so it
gets to $8 a share so it gets to 8 it
gets to $8 a share so this is the market
up this is the market up scenario now
let's imagine the market down scenario
mark it mark it down so now my position
in B goes from $10 $10 to $8 $10 to $8
so I lose so I lose $2 on my long
position but when the market went down I
was right a is not that great of a
company so it goes down more let's
imagine that it goes down by 50% so a
goes down by 50%
down by 50% all the way to 2 dollars 50
per share so it's now at $2 50 per share
so my position in a the short position
that was $10 it is now a $5 short
position two shares at 250 per share so
this is a short position
I sold the stock and I borrowed and sold
it at 10 now I can buy it back at 5 I
make I make $5 on the short position
when the market goes down so even though
I lost some money on my long position
when the market goes down I'm more than
make up for it on my short position so
even in the down market assuming my
stock picking is good I have still made
I have still made $3 and so what we've
set up here is a long short hedge and
what's cool about it is it's only
dependent on the investors ability to
differentiate between companies that are
more or less likely to do well relative
to other companies and it's not as
dependent on someone's ability to pick
which direction the market itself will
be going and so when people talk about
long short hedge funds they're talking
about hedge funds that are essentially
doing this their
trying to hedge out the market risk